اردوغان يتعهد بفوز تاريخي ومنافسه ساقاتل
حتى النهايه هجوما ضخم ثامن على كييف
بالمسيرات والكروز تطوير تقنيه جديده قد
تحدث ثوره بتشخيص نوبات القلب هذه الاخبار
وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه العربيه فاهلا
بكم الى التفاصيل
في انتظار الجوله الثانيه من الانتخابات
التي ستعقد بعد اسبوعين بدا كل من رجب طيب
اردوغان ومنافسه كمال كليتش
انصارهما اردوغان الذي تقدم على منافسه
المعارض في الجوله الاولى اعتبر ان الجوله
الثانيه ستتوج بفوزه وستكون بمثابه بشرى
لرؤيه قرن تركيا واكد ان الاصوات التي حصل
عليها ستتضاعف فيما نشر اوغلو مقطع فيديو
على حسابه على تويتر قال فيه انه سيقاتل
حتى النهايه في هذه الانتخابات
سيقضت العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف صباح هذا
اليوم على دوري انفجارات قويه هزت ارجاء
المدينه وزاره دفاع الاوكرانيه افادت
بانها اسقطت سته صواريخ روسيه فرض صوتيه
من طراز كنجال في سماء كيف وهو نوع من
الاسلحه التي يصعب اعتراضها مضيفه ان
القوات الروسيه استخدم الطائرات بدون طيار
وصواريخ كروز وربما صواريخ باليستيه في
ثامن هجوم شهدته العاصمه خلال الشهر
الجاري اكدت الوزاره ان الغالبيه العظمى
من تلك الصواريخ والمسيارات دمرت واسقطت
تبقى معكم في اوكرانيا كشف محققون عن
تسجيل فساد واسع النطاق في المحكمه العليا
مؤكدين فتح تحقيقات حول حصول بعض القضاه
على مكاسب غير مشروعه في سياق ذاتها افادت
رويترز بان رئيس المحكمه
العليازيد ثقل للاشتباه في تلقيح رشوه
بقيمه ثلاثه ملايين دولار فيما نشرت
السلطات الاوكرانيه على منصه تيليجرام
نشرت صوره لاكوام من الدولارات مصفوفه على
اريكه كاشفه على ان حجز هذه الاموال جاء
بعد تحقيقات اجراها مكتب محاربه الفساد
ومكتب المدعي العام الخاص لمكافحه الفساد
بعيدا عن عالم السياسه طور باحثون
بريطانيون خوارزميه جديده تعتمد على
الذكاء الاصطناعي قد تساعد الاطباء في
تشخيص النوبات القلبيه بسرعه وبدقه ووفقا
للباحثين من جامعه ادمرا فان الخوارزمي
الجديد كانت قادره على استبعاد النوبه
القلبيه لاكثر من ضعف عدد المرضى الذين
شملتهم البحث وبدقه تصل الى
99.6% مقارنه باساليب الاختبار الحاليه
كما قد تساعد الاداء ايضا بشكل كبير في
تقليل حالات الدخول الى المستشفى والتعرف
حتى بسرعه على المرضى الذين يمكنهم العوده
الى منازلهم بامان
وفي خبرنا الاخير حطم استاذ جامعي الرقم
القياسي للعيش باطول وقت ممكن في الماء
داخل نزل مخصص للغواصينا
الباحث جوزيف ديتوري قضى 74 يوما تحت
الماء في النزل الواقع باسفل البحيره بعمق
عشره امتار وعلى عكس الغواصه لا يستخدم
ولا يتم استخدام هذا النزل بالتكنولوجيا
اللازمه لضبط الضغط المتزايد تحت الماء
فيما لن يكتفي ديتوري بهذا الرقم وقال انه
يخطط البقاء في النزل حتى التاسع من يونيو
المقبل عندما يبلغ المائه يوم
[موسيقى]